- This is how Albert is.
I mean, he's like a
little doll. (laughing)
(upbeat instrumental music)
Albert is three years old.
He was the runt of the litter
and he was really tiny.
Albert was on Cat From
Hell for a licking problem,
and we were also on Animal Planet
for the show called
America's Next Cat Star,
and they put a bunch of
cats that are predicted
to become famous.
I started his Instagram
account when I went
to a cat festival.
People were just ooh-ing
and aah-ing over him.
Albert has not always been famous.
He's been made famous by heavy marketing.
Albert's most notable post would be his
moonwalking, where I
put Albert on the window
ledge and I started filming him.
I was like, Albert come here. (clicking)
But his butt was facing me, and then
all of a sudden, he
started walking backwards,
and I put it up on
Instagram and instantly,
the comments just flooded in.
It was like everybody was
tagging all their friends.
(gentle ambient music)
Albert's costumes are really hard to find
because you can't really find
that many good pet costumes.
The ones in pet stores are usually
low quality so I had to, we get creative.
We usually shop at Babies
R Us, or try to find
human infant clothes.
So the way we usually do shoots
is he gets distracted a lot.
So I put him in a costume.
We'll have to have some toys.
Albert. (squeaking)
It's like he knows that
he's being photographed
so he'll do everything
in his power to look away
from the camera.
Oh, look at that.
We do a lot of sponsored posts.
The biggest ones we've done
are for Coca-Cola, Walgreens.
Yeah, and we did one
for the Deadpool movie.
When we first started,
it was very difficult
of us to get sponsored posts.
(clicks)
We were only being
approached by pet companies.
I worked really hard on Albert's account
with his photos, and I do this full time
so I thought why not?
Why can't we get some sponsors?
At first, we got a lot of
people that didn't understand
the sponsored content,
especially because he's a cat
advertising products that
are not related to pets.
So what people don't
understand is that we love
doing Albert posts and videos and photos
but just because we love it doesn't mean
that we shouldn't get paid for it.
If people really love
Albert, like they should
be understanding of
that, that we're putting
so much work into this.
We can't afford to do it
for free all the time.
I worked so hard on getting more followers
everyday, it's a day to day thing.
Every single day is me thinking about,
okay, what's the next step?
My goal in life is
always to do what I love.
That's what I've been doing with Albert.
I love him so much, and it's so much fun
spending time with him.
I'm taking videos and photos of him.
I've turned my hobby into a career.
(gentle instrumental music)